joining us now is the science minister
george freeman mr freeman good to talk
to you this morning thank you for
joining us we were promised a plan by
your colleagues rowlite plan uh earlier
on this week where's the plan
morning kay yeah good to join you um
today we've got all of the global fire
pharma leaders here in london to
announce another half a billion pound
package
into uk life science and as your report
highlights this pandemic isn't over and
the uk is leading in both the science of
defeating this virus
and in the rollout package for vaccines
here in the uk we've procured another
114 million doses so we've got the doses
here for patients over the next few
months and we're in a global race to
make sure we defeat this pandemic and
i'm here today to talk about how uk
science is right on the front line of
that we're working across government to
lead the global fight to defeat the
virus
and an answer to my
question yeah so we're we're working
right now across government on how we
both uh accelerate the rollout
internationally of vaccines the truth is
we're not safe until the world is safe
and the uk has led that charge we've
invested more per capita than any other
nation we're huge supporters of kovacs
and at the g7 summit
this summer we led the charge on how
globally we support international
rollout here in the uk our vaccine
rollout program is setting the benchmark
and that's why we're able this year to
not impose
the very tough uh quite draconian
regulations we had to last year
in a way that other countries are so
this is uk science leadership and nhs
leadership and the vaccine rollout
program
leading
here in the uk in terms of science but
also allowing our citizens to enjoy
fewer restrictions than in other
countries
on monday we were promised a plan it's
thursday we haven't got a plan people
don't know when they can have their
boosters where's the plan
the nhs i'll
have a plan it's being rolled out and
people can apply now i've just had my
text last night my booster appointment
uh has been offered for next week and
people across my constituency and around
the country are able now to get their
boosters and i would having had covered
myself three weeks ago this is not a
nice disease i was double jabbed went
down for a week and i would encourage
everybody
contact your gp get on the app
book your booster jab the nhs is
there we're rolling it out we've
procured the vaccines and we're leading
the world in that rollout so this is
good news i just encourage everyone
to make sure we get there
yeah in your 20s and 30s when can you go
onto the app to book your job
so if you contact your gp there are
slight differences around the country um
but at the moment we're the first
country to get to this point we've got
eighty percent of the whole country
double jabbed uh and uh we've got uh
nearly uh ninety percent of the whole
country first jabbed and we're now
rolling it out fast now some gp
practices are rolling slightly quicker
than others
and that's what you'd expect but uh if
people contact their gp now and go on
the app they can book uh to get their
their booster jabbing or their second
channel that's not true minister you
can't get your booster at the moment if
you're in your twenties the question is
we were told earlier in the week that we
wouldn't there's a plan i'm just asking
you where the plan is and when people in
their 20s and 30s can book their booster
well the nhs are leading on that role
that i haven't got on my fingertips
today exactly which gp practices are
making it available today but we are
accelerating that rollout and it is key
uh and we were we are uh putting that in
place so that the next generation uh the
next age cohort can get uh their booster
jab as quickly as possible but uh the
nhs has got uh to put that alongside
clearing the back club of cancer cases
and all of the other issues that the
pandemic has caused i think the public
understand that we have to do everything
we can we are the nhs is flat out i was
in constituency surgeries in my patch
last week and the booster rollout and
the jab program is working i'm not
getting a lot of complaints from people
saying the uk is behind on its
vaccination program of course we all
need to move fast and we are and the nhs
is doing that that's why we've put more
money in we only have a limited minister
we only have a limited amount of time
the answer is you don't know the answer
let me let me put this to you south
africa averaging 300 cases no you don't
the answer if you're only 20.
if you're in your 20s you don't know
when you can have the job just just
admit to that because that's that is
fundamentally the case isn't it
the case is that the nhs is rolling out
the vaccine program and if you contact
your gp and book it you will get your
your your jab it's not true it's just
not true it's just not true minister um
south africa um averaging 300 cases a
day that has led to eight and a half
thousand cases yesterday how concerned
are we
yeah well as the prime minister and the
health secretary child secretary have
set out we are concerned that's why
we've put in place
uh some pretty important reasonable
measures to make sure that red list
countries have to test before they come
we're trying to make sure that the
global economy can carry on working
while minimizing the risk and i think
that's the key we in those countries
where
the new variant is surging we need to be
quite tough and make sure that people
aren't bringing it in contain it
and then when it's here make sure that
we're containing it here in the uk we
did it before we've learned a huge
amount in the last year and we'll do it
again and today
we've got all the global leaders in the
vaccine industry here because the uk is
leading the charge globally this is a
pandemic it isn't over yet and the uk is
leading in making sure that we both
tackle the virus
and make sure that we're leading in the
rollout program
given that how many doses have we
delivered to kovacs we promised 100
million didn't we
yeah the problem with kovacs actually
has been and i set a up a commission
last year before coming back into
government that the global manufacturing
supply chains for example india a major
manufacturer of vaccines around the
world india was hit really hard by the
pandemic and one of the things we set
out in our g7 summit in the summer which
is partly what we're picking up today is
to make sure that we've got those global
supply chains so britain has put the
funding in we've procured the vaccines
the key is getting the roll out
internationally into some of those
hard-to-reach countries in africa in the
some of the pacific island states and
that is a global challenge that's why
we're one of the biggest contributors to
kovacs who are doing a brilliant job
we've put the vaccines in we've got to
make sure that we support them in
rolling them out internationally because
as i say
we're not safe the global economy isn't
safe until we've defeated this pandemic
across the whole world
we promised a hundred million how many
have we delivered
we've we've supported that 100 million
they're in the pipeline that isn't the
issue okay the issue is getting them out
around the country which is why we're
focusing today on
how many of we've delivered
i'm sorry i'm sorry how many have we
delivered of the 100 million that we
promised you mean have we
have we delivered to kovacs
yes
yeah we we're on schedule i haven't got
that number at my fingertips now but we
are
on schedule the issue isn't lack of you
yeah that but that isn't what's holding
up the global rollout program okay
what's holding it up as i say is that
international
supply chain issue around the world and
nobody is saying we're not getting them
enough because the uk hasn't supported
so why why are we taking so many more um
uh vaccines uh here in the uk then tens
of millions more of what we've ordered
shouldn't we given that we're not safe
until everyone's safe shouldn't we be
diverting those to third world countries
so it's a balance okay i mean we've got
another variant i think the british
public would expect us to make sure that
we've made sure to your earlier point in
this interview that we're providing the
supply here in the uk and that's why
we've just procured another 114 million
doses precisely to make sure we can
deliver that roll out here in the uk as
well this is a balance we've got to make
sure that our citizens are safe
and that the global vaccine roll out
through kovacs is supported
and that is what we're committed to
doing and it's why today we've got as
part of that g7 follow-up all the global
leaders in vaccine science here in the
sure we're uk to focus on it
okay um right we've got that's right
okay because it's an international
challenge because we only have a short
period of time as you know minister it's
always difficult when you're not with me
because obviously we
i i'm interrupting you so forgive me for
that uh given that you say that we need
more vaccines in the uk are we going to
inoculate five to 11 year olds they are
in italy and they are in israel
well we're looking at that the science
on that and the balance of roll out
patrick balance as our chief scientist
and chris whittie are advising on that
and it's their advice that guides us the
urgent priority now as you highlighted
earlier is to make sure that we roll out
the jab program through the population
and with christmas coming we want to
make sure that as many people as
possible are double jabbed
i think in due course we would like to
make sure that
all of those who are vulnerable have the
right level of protection the data at
the moment suggests that young children
are much much less
vulnerable but as and when that data
changes we're guided by the science and
we stand ready as partly why we've
procured the vaccines to make sure that
we can deliver what our citizens and
patients need
okay we are out of town i just want to
ask you one final question before i let
you go though minister if you will
indulge me apparently emmanuel macron
has uh said it's very sad to see a great
country with which we could do so much
led by a clown
uh talking about boris johnson what
would you say in response
well i think we're into pantomime season
aren't we and there's a french election
coming it's a pretty unhelpful word of
course the prime minister's in the clown
he's the elected prime minister of this
country with a very big mandate leading
this country through the pandemic the
truth is we are looking to work very
closely with france on the border issue
on tackling the problem of european
migration at source that's why we're
investing in trying to stabilize
countries so that people aren't coming
here and with france we need to make
sure that people in fro in france aren't
being supplied with boats and being
pushed out into the channel the home
secretary is working closely with french
counterparts on it and the prime
minister and the uk government is
looking for a sensible conversation with
france about it so uh i i'm confident
that actually anglo-french relations are
rather better than that quote suggests
are you planning a lovely christmas
well
i think all of us are hoping that this
christmas we'll be able to enjoy
more freedom than we did last christmas
um
but uh you know we're in this pandemic
and hopefully this new variant isn't
going to sweep through
the country and we won't have to put in
place those restrictions last year and
the vaccine program is our best defense
against that um so i think everyone
as the prime minister said should be
able to plan for christmas but we're
going to have to be sensible and that's
why we've upped the guidance
masks on public transport
masks in shops but we also want people
to be able to go to
clubs and to pubs and be able to have a
drink
and eat which you can't do if you're
wearing a mask it's common sense really
i think the british public understand
that the more we can prevent the
transmission of the virus the more we'll
be able to enjoy the freedoms we all
cherish and
to me wearing a mask on a tube in winter
weather particularly isn't onerous and i
think if we wear masks in shops and on
public transport we've got a higher
chance of being able to enjoy those
freedoms we all cherish
okay good to talk to you minister thank
you so much for taking the time much
appreciated
thank you